after turning 40 this year i realized
like no i don't want
a husband that lives in a completely
different state
to me i thought oh my god that's when
we're getting along the best
but then that is sad to me kim
kardashian reveals the moment she knew
she wanted a divorce from kanye west
i didn't come this far just to come this
far and not be happy
it all went down on the series finale of
keeping up with the kardashians on
e during a chat between the kkw beauty
founder
and her mom kris jenner kim got candid
about her life with the rapper which has
been split in recent years between their
california home and their wyoming ranch
i never thought i was lonely and i never
i always thought that's totally fine i
could just have my kids
my husband moves from state to state and
i just
i'm on this ride with him and i was okay
with that and then after turning 40 this
year
i realized like no i don't want
a husband that lives in a completely
different state
to me i thought oh my god that's when
we're getting along the best
but then that is sad to me and that's
not what i want
kim also explains that she's achieved
quote 10 times more
than she ever thought was possible in
her life but doesn't quote
have a life to share that with i want
someone that
we have the same shows in common i want
someone that wants to work out with me
it's like the little things is what i
don't have i have all the big things
yeah i have the extravagant everything
you could possibly imagine and no one
will ever do it like that i know that
you know what i mean and i'm grateful
for those experiences but
i think i'm ready for the smaller
experiences that i think will mean a lot
the skim's founder says she doesn't want
to rush to any big decisions but her
goal
is quote total happiness obviously
complete bliss is like not a full
reality but if i can have it more of the
majority of the time
that's all i want to do wherever that
takes me i just want
my pure happiness so that's what i'm
working on figuring out how to get there
you're very strong girl and you seem to
handle
everything very calmly calmness is my
superpower
the 40 year old reality star filed for
divorce from kanye after six years of
marriage in february
and a source previously told et that kim
wouldn't shy away from addressing her
highly publicized marital issues
on the 20th and final season of keeping
up
i honestly can't do this anymore
why am i still in this like place where
i'm stuck for years like he goes and
moves to a different state everywhere i
have to be
like together so i can raise the kids
you know he's an amazing dad he's done
an amazing job the whole world he still
will be
during part one of the series finale
fans got their first look at what kim
was really going through in her marriage
he deserves someone that can go support
his every move and go follow him all
over the place and move to wyoming i
can't do that he should have a wife that
supports his every move and travels with
him and does everything and i just yeah
i feel like a [ __ ] failure that it's
like a third marriage
yeah i feel like a loser but i can't
even think about that like i want to be
happy and despite all those tears
last month the source told et that kim
is quote in a great headspace
and moving on in the months since filing
for divorce
adding that she's really focused on her
family and has
been spending the majority of her time
with the kids
in life what i've learned is you just
kind of have to go with
it kim is continuing to be a great mom
and focusing on work her life is
definitely
on the upswing
[Music]